dans ce quartier bombardé de micola yves
la poussière n'est pas encore retombée
employés municipaux et volontaires sont
déjà à pied d'oeuvre
il reste des choses il y un climatiseur
les habitants font la queue pour du film
plastique de quoi remplacer les vitres
cassées
deux mètres et demi le balcon ça fait
deux mètres et demi plus deux mètres et
demi supplémentaires
depuis l'invasion il ne s'est pas passé
une semaine sans des appels comme celui
ci parfois il ya une pause pendant un
jour ou deux mais c'est rare en fête est
devenue notre quotidien
ailleurs dans le centre ville une autre
ambiance
merci pour votre intérêt dans le cinéma
ukrainien originale et de qualité
les visiteurs prennent place dans un
abri antibombes sous un théâtre pour un
festival de cinéma
désolé l'acteur principal n'a pas pu
venir il est dans l'armée maintenant
le film met en scène des tatars de
crimée exilé depuis l'annexion russe en
2014 une histoire qui résonne d'autant
plus aujourd'hui
nous pensons que la culture c'est
important et refaire des projections de
films amis collègues c'est une très
bonne manière d'aider ceux qui sont
restés ici sur la première ligne de
défense à croire en la victoire que la
paix reviendra un jour dans leur
dans la salle et malgré son barda nitro
n'a pas oublié son ancien métier
critiques de cinéma vous avez une main
la vie continue toujours en temps de
guerre on ne se bat pas simplement pour
se battre pour parvenir à la paix et des
événements comme celui-ci sont une
manifestation de la si on passait tout
son temps à se cacher on pourrait perdre
la raison
nicolas yves est devenu un symbole de la
résistance ukrainienne c'est ici qu'est
s'est arrêtée l'offensif russe dans le
sud en mars et aujourd'hui la ville est
au coeur de l'effort ukrainien pour
reprendre et personne à seulement 60
kilomètres au sud-est